quand tu vas aller à New York tu vas
visiter la Maison Blanche
[Applaudissements]
alors dis-moi non il y a un truc quand
même sélecteur studio tu es d'accord
j'ai commencé les cours à Paris
justement
[Musique]
alors est-ce que tu pourrais me jouer la
peur
la symbolique était la colère
moi je trouve que les sentiments et pas
de gigolo gigolo
un homme qui dit je t'aime avec les yeux
arrête avec la [ __ ]
tu veux faire comprendre à une femme qui
l'avait là tout de suite maintenant
je sais que tu es marié
s'il te plaît
[Rires]
alors maintenant voilà
l'acteur qu'elle a marre de pas être
pris au sérieux
la palette des mecs
est-ce que tu peux jouer
l'inquiétude de la star devant le voici
du lundi matin
ouais tu peux me jouer la fleur qui
pousse
[Musique]
jeux silencieux
je le fais tous les soirs au théâtre
alors viens me voir au théâtre de
Trévise du mardi au samedi à 20h et
j'invite tout le monde à venir vous voir
parce que c'est vraiment marrant vous
allez vous éclater c'est une comédie à
mourir de rire sérieusement faut venir
ou pas
pour être sûr de ne rien rater le
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu